hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
and today we're going to dive once again
into the meaning of life
in fact the meaning of many things what
is meaning what are
purposes that we have out there in the
world but we're going to do this in a
much more grounded
scientific way than we usually do or
than people usually do when talking
about these things
which is appropriate for the modern
world you know back in the day
before the scientific revolution before
darwin and his friends
you could imagine that purposes and
meanings were simply part of the
fundamental
furniture of reality if you were
aristotle or one of his successors
you imagine that a final purpose a final
cause
was one of the things you needed to
explain how things work the final cause
was
the thing to which you aimed right your
ultimate future goal it was a
teleological
way of thinking about the world but then
along comes physics of course but mostly
along comes darwin and darwin is able to
explain
all of the species all the biology we
have around us
in ways that don't refer to future goals
at all
right this is one of the secrets of
evolution that even though
individual species can be very very well
adapted to their environments
it doesn't come from precognition it
doesn't come from planning for the
future
individual parts of our genomes shake
about randomly or recombine through
sexual reproduction and so forth
and they just figure out through trial
and error which ones work for the
situations they're in right now there's
no
forward-lookingness at all so here's the
puzzle then if that's true if darwin is
right and there is no
forward-lookingness in the process of
biology
why is it that so many things in the
world in the natural world
seem to have purposes seem to be
existing
for reasons right this is what drives
people to intelligent design
and things like that why is the neck of
the giraffe
so long well it seems to have the
purpose of reaching the leaves up there
in the tree right
and on a piecemeal basis you can account
for these things using non-teleological
evolutionary biology but maybe you want
a bigger picture of you
an idea of how purposes and meanings
come to exist through the
non-teleological or distilliological is
a technical word
operation of ordinary natural selection
so today's guest is david hague
who is a professor at harvard of
organismic and evolutionary biology
he's a theorist so he thinks widely
about many many things and he has a new
book out called from darwin to dera da
selfish genes social selves and the
meanings
of life and i'm not going to give away
too much we'll talk about on the podcast
but the basic idea is exactly this to
sort of
figure out how purposes can evolve
despite the fact that evolution is not
forward-looking
to be very honest i have a difficult
time translating or sort of saying what
he says because it's actually
very similar to things that i say in my
own book
the big picture and so i end up putting
my words into his mouth which is not
fair
so you should listen to what david has
to say it's a fascinating sort of
synthesis of a whole bunch of different
ideas
from different places and the other
reason i wanted to invite david on the
podcast is because i was tickled
by the appearance of jacques derrida's
name in the title of his book jacques
derek one of the leading lights of
postmodern
philosophy and and you know modern
theoretical french philosophy
which as i mentioned in the podcast is
kind of anathema
to a lot of sciency people uh on this
side of the atlantic ocean especially
and it's interesting to me because i
think that deredah and his postmodern
friends
get way too much flack and they're not
taken nearly seriously enough by
scientists uh my friends
who are scientists out there i'm not
going to say that i agree with
everything that daredev or other
postmodernists talk about
but there's a certain anti-intellectual
attitude
that doesn't actually read the books a
bunch of people right just
strawmens them as forces of anti-reason
and so forth and i think that
in the case of dereda and others there
is something useful in
there that can be used even if you
disregard or
just disagree with other parts of it and
i think that's exactly what
david does his particular reason for
invoking darada's name in the title of
his book
has to do with a similarity between the
fact that daradah makes a big deal about
how
meanings in texts are not foundational
they are not part of the ultimate
structure of the text just like
darwin comes along and says that
purposes and meanings are not
part of the fundamental architecture of
reality or science
to dara da meaning is continually being
rewritten as different people read text
in different ways and other texts are
written and so forth
and so david thought it would be funny
to actually compare them in the book and
he has a joke i'm not going to give away
the joke but the joke appears in the
podcast anyway
i think that uh people should be much
more open-minded
about parts of academic work that are
very far away from theirs
seem very alien to them and are hard to
understand but might actually have
something to offer even if it's only
piecemeal and i think that daradah is a
good example of that so anyway
that is that's my little sales pitch for
reading post-modernism as a modern
uh physical or natural scientist and
with that let's go
[Music]
david hey welcome to the mindscape
podcast welcome sean
this is going to be a conversation where
i have to restrain myself a little bit
because you've written
a book uh that in many ways is sort of
complementary to
a book that i wrote called the big
picture there's a lot more evolutionary
biology in your book there's more
physics in my book but
it's going from the natural world of
science to questions of purpose and
meaning so maybe to situate ourselves
what would cause an evolutionary
biologist to
write a book about purpose and meaning
so since my undergraduate education i
have been told in biology that
using teleological language is
unscientific
that anthropomorphism is another
sin in biology and yet when we think
about biology
the first thing that comes to our
attention is the purposiveness of
living beings and the scientists who
decry using teleological language will
be quite happy
talking about receptors and signals and
information transfer within cells
not to mention transcription and
translation
which are very teleological concepts
so i'm 62 and i was becoming
increasingly frustrated
that in evolutionary biology good ideas
based on arguments from adaptation were
being rejected
for bad philosophic reason well that's
very interesting so do you think that uh
when you say bad philosophical reasons
um i'm very familiar with
the relationship between physics and
philosophy which is
rather a hostile one from the
physicist's point of view and i think
that's bad
uh do but how do biologists feel about
philosophy when you say bad
philosophical reasons are these just
biologists offering reasons that that
are philosophical even though they
wouldn't characterize them that way or
is it that they're actually listening to
bad philosophy
no i i think that they would feel that
their empirical research is independent
of
philosophical presuppositions but
usually they have a whole series of
assumptions that they're making that
they don't question themselves
right and so that's why i thought i
needed to
delve into some of these assumptions
within biology
that makes a lot of sense you know i
often say that it you don't have a
choice as a as a scientist to not
do philosophy but you can do it in an
informed way or in a
in a less informed way so speaking of
philosophy then you know let's
just to sort of again set the stage a
little bit here
like many people you go all the way to
aristotle when you're talking about
causes and purposes so uh maybe
share with the audience i mean you've
already used the word teleology explain
what that means and how it relates to
our notion of causes and purposes
so teleology comes from the greek word
t los which refers to the end of
something
for biologists they will know of
telomeres which are the end of
chromosomes so aristotle was
trying to think about different
explanations we offered
of things and he offered four different
kinds of explanations one was
explanation in terms of the material
from which something was made
another was an explanation in terms of
the idea or form of the material
so that the same material could make
many different things that differed in
form
and he also what set something in motion
and then the purpose or first
the thing for the sake of which
something existed
right and when aristotle's ideas were um
translated into
latin they used the latin term causa
which was originally a legal term um
to show probable cause still to this day
legal system and so his four causes
came down in medieval philosophy as the
material cause
that was the matter of which something
was made the formal cause
which was the essence of the thing what
made it that matter one kind of thing
rather than another
the efficient cause which was what set
something in motion
and then the final cause which was
the thing the reason why the thing
existed
the end to which it um moved and so in
the
scientific revolution um physicists
largely rejected formal and final causes
in favor of
efficient and material causes that all
explanation
was to be of matter in motion and that
was
highly successful in physics but in
biology at that time
people continued to think in terms of
purposes and final courses
so william harvey described the
circulation of the blood
by thinking about what might be the
function of the
valves in veins and so up until the 19th
century
final causes explanations in terms of
purposes
were used by most physiologists
and um biologists it's interesting
because
the phraseology the the translation of
aristotle's ideas into the word cause
doesn't quite fit our informal notion
right like a material cause the stuff
out of which something is made
that's that we wouldn't call that a
cause at all but the the final cause the
purpose
and the efficient cause whatever makes
it those are things that really do
resonate with our
notions of causes and as you point out
science
has had something to say about these
notions yes yes
so i think um so um the word aristotle
was using
you might think of it as more like an
explanation right and so he was talking
about four different
explanations um that moved into the
latinos called
causa and then into uh um english's um
cause the um the final cause
um has been the most controversial
within um
science because it seems to be
explaining
the existence something of something by
the effects that it has
yeah and but the effects are coming
after um
sorry the effects come before the the um
cause
and that seems to be reversing um our
conception of causation
right right well so and this is where we
get really into the the nitty-gritty so
we're uh we're not going to save the
best for last we're going to get right
into it right now
um you know when darwin comes along and
and explains natural selection which is
uh evolution and the the the name of the
department you're in at harvard it
contains that word evolution
right in it uh in some sense you know
one interpretation was
he got rid of the need for teleology for
for purpose you know when when
evolutionary changes happen
uh they don't know ahead of time what is
going to be the effect that those
changes
have and they're selected after the fact
um so i think a lot of people would say
you know we don't need to talk that
language anymore of teleology darwin
explained it all away
but you want to say that nevertheless
that language is useful somehow
yes i think darwin's own position was
that he cannot eliminated teleology
that he had naturalized purpose in
nature
and so that previously um the conception
a purpose required some mind which had
intentions and
plans and so natural theology had
explained um
the purposiveness of living things as
evidence for the creator
and what i think darwin showed is that
you had a perfectly natural
process which didn't have a purpose that
created
living beings living beings with
purposes and intentions
evolved so um my feeling of um
darwin's own position was that he hadn't
eliminated purpose
and he actually in his own writings
particularly on plants use of purpose of
language frequently but that he had got
rid of the need for some
supernatural source of the purpose and i
think the
the heart of the teleology in darwin
only really became clear when we had a
concept of
genetic materials that are copied and
transmitted
from one generation to the next and so
now the
effects of a gene can determine whether
that gene is copied or
not so it's what a gene does that is
responsible for its presence
in the population of course it means
what it did in the past
that is responsible for its presence now
but
it will tend to do again the things that
it did in the past
in the present and so there is a
forward-looking nature to natural
selection because of the recursion
that is present in reproduction right i
mean this is a deep idea that maybe is
is worth uh uh going into more details
about
so what what you're saying what you seem
to be saying is that
uh i mean not only did darwin remove the
need for
a mind designing these things but that
somehow
the wonderful trick that evolution pulls
off
is to give things purposes without
directly looking into the future right
without directly having foresight it
works in the present moment
but in such a way that usefulness in the
future comes along for the ride
yes so he darwin got
rid of the idea that there was a a
purpose in creation
um that evolution was working towards
some
future goal but he created a process
that created beings like you and i
that interact with their environments in
purposive ways
so the evolutionary process itself
doesn't have
any purpose direction or end but it
creates meaningful beings that act
purposefully
in their environments yeah i mean maybe
we can uh
make that more precise or maybe it's
something that is just hard to make
precise i mean
when do c when can we point to something
that an organism is doing and saying
this is a purpose for this uh aspect of
the organism or this this action that
the organism takes
so if one of its past actions
um is responsible for so now now i'll
do it specifically not from the organism
but from
the genetic text if one of the effects
of
a particular genetic text is responsible
for that text being copied and being
present today
then it is those effects of the text
that account for
the present presence of the gene so we
have genes that cause hearts to pump
which circulate um oxygen to the tissues
of the
body that is their function in the past
organisms have um survived because they
have functional
hearts that distribute oxygen and so
it's the
the past functioning of the heart that
explains
the um presence today of genes that um
produce
functional hearts 2020 is almost over
and it's already reshaped how we work
businesses across the globe are
challenged to be their most efficient
which means every hire is critical and
indeed
is here to help indeed is the number one
job site in the world
indeed helps you find quality candidates
quickly so you can focus on hiring the
person you need to keep your business
going
unlike other sites indeed gives you full
control and payment flexibility over
your hiring
you only pay for what you need you can
pause your account at any time
and there are no long-term contracts and
now indeed's new way of matching you
with candidates instantly
delivers a short list of quality
candidates whose resumes on indeed
match your job criteria that you can
contact the moment you sponsor a job
making indeed the only job site that can
move as fast as you do
and right now indeed is offering our
listeners a free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means more quality candidates will see
it
fast try indeed out with a free 75
credit at indeed.com mindscape
this is their best offer available
anywhere so go right now
to indeed.com mindscape offer valid
through december 31
terms and conditions apply do you tend
yourself to think of this in terms of
emergence and levels of description i
mean can we say that
in some sense at the microscopic level
of the molecules inside our dna
uh things just obey the laws of
chemistry right i mean they just bump
into each other and combine or recombine
and talk of purposes
uh isn't very helpful but once we look
at a higher level where you talk about
genes or organisms or traits then the
language of purposes becomes more useful
so i i would say both yes and no
yes in the sense that natural selection
is just an explanation of an incredible
complicated process of efficient causes
of organisms living and interacting with
other
organisms in a complex environment and
so to
summarize it as selection for some
particular character is just an
efficient way of talking about that
very very complex process that of course
obeys
physical laws so i'm a real believer
that there are no special
causes that everything is ultimately
physical and chemical causation so
that's the yes to your question
the no is to somebody who says that
everything
um can be built up from the ground up
and then you have emergence
at higher levels the nature of natural
selection is that it's events
in the world of ecology in the world of
interactions among organisms who
gets to mate who gets to reproduce that
have effects at the molecular
level so that the explanation for
example of why
the sickle cell mutation occurs in um
in a hemoglobin gene in people of
african descent
is because they came from an environment
where
malaria was endemic and that particular
amino acid change provides some
resistance against malarial infection
so the causation is going to the amino
acid in the protein
from the complex world of epidemiology
and the subsistence agriculture of those
people in the past well yeah so we see
what we're getting immediately into
tricky philosophical waters uh about
yeah one of the many issues that is
brought up by this kind of thing is
what counts as real right uh our mutual
friend
dan dennett uh previous mindscape
podcast guest and
he wrote the forward to your book uh he
really likes to emphasize that these
higher level
emerging things are real there are
patterns
you use the word efficient an efficient
way of talking about things well then
that's a real feature of the world and
so
is it is it safe to say that purposes
fall into that category
yes i i would accept them as being
real and we we see that in our own
um actions um you you and i are talking
to each other we have a
purpose of producing this podcast
there is some incredibly complex um
physical chemical explanation of what
we're we are doing
but that explanation is actually not
particularly explanatory
of the sort of questions i ask and the
uh
or the questions you ask and the answers
i give to them
right so explanation at that level um
the physical chemical substrate of it's
essentially irrelevant
um to explanation at that particular
level
and i would say the same is true of
understanding the adaptations of um
organisms sometimes um physical chemical
information is relevant but sometimes
it's just a distraction i think a
really interesting comparison now is to
um the success of the current success of
artificial intelligence
so artificial intelligences are trained
by a process of selection
from feedback from their output
back into the nodes of the network
now an artificial intelligence network
is absolutely transparent
you can get a printout of all of the
connections within the
network and their strengths and yet
people in artificial intelligence find
it very hard to understand
how the network achieves what it um what
it does
the modification of the network has been
non-linear and complex by feedback from
the complicated
environment and so actually just knowing
the way that
electrons are flowing through the
network is not giving
a lit much insight into what are the
capabilities of that particular um
artificial intelligence good no i think
that we're exactly on the same
uh wavelength here which leads me to uh
ask are there people who are not on this
wavelength
are there people who disagree with you
about this particular conception of
how we should think about where purposes
come from in biology
um yes it's an absolute part of dogma
for most biologists
that um talking using purposive language
is non-scientific and i am still
regularly
corrected to this day in the papers i
submit to
scientific journals that um that my use
of the language of purpose
is inappropriate and that i am making
some fundamental
mistake about biological organisms
a related criticism is against treating
um other organisms anthropomorphically
as if they were like humans
and i find that rather strange you know
it's okay to
treat a slug i talk about slugs quite a
bit in the
book as if they were like a machine but
totally inappropriate to think of them
as in some ways like
human beings even though they share even
though i would say a slug and a human
being are much more
similar to each other than they are to a
a traffic light or even a digital um
computer
but for mechanistic biologists
machine analogies are appropriate
whereas
talk of um purposes and reasons
and intentions are inappropriate in
explaining the behaviors
of living things so i can think of a
couple reasons why that might be the
case
is one of them just that there's an
ongoing debate in evolutionary biology
about the role of
uh adaptations in evolution versus just
accidents uh i just had sean b carroll
the biologist evil twin of mine on the
show and
and he was is on the side of really
emphasizing how important
accidents are uh but clearly there's
also an
adaptationist aspect to evolution and is
that part of why people resist
the talk of purposes because sometimes
things just happen by accident
so accident of course is a very very
important part of natural selection
all mutations which are the raw
materials on which
the environment selects are essentially
copying
accidents so i'm a real believer in the
importance of
of chance but which of those chants
which of those mutations are um
interpreted by the environment
as adaptive or non-adaptive that's a
post-hoc judgment by the environment
yeah so dna sequences are accumulating
information about past natural selection
so
random processes are important but i
think
um people in evo devo like the other
sean carroll
part of part of the reason why they want
to emphasize the random against the
adaptation
is this teleophobia that's sitting there
if you're a serious scientist
um there's something more rigorous and
hard-nosed about
um looking for random explanations
rather than adaptive explanations it's
perceived as being
soft or poor science now it's very very
easy to make a bad adaptationist
argument
i'm not saying that identifying what the
adaptations of organisms are is easy
but to just give up on that process and
to
um to focus on random processes
which neutral evolution which by
definition doesn't make a difference for
the um
organism i think is missing what's
really really distinctive about biology
yeah i think that i mean everyone
probably agrees that both
uh neutral genetic drift is is happens
and is important and also
adaptation of selection happens and is
important then balancing them
is tricky and then the other thing that
happens you know
in biology at least as opposed to
physics for example
is that the discussion is embedded in
this
political and theological context in a
way that physics just isn't
are people worried about using the
vocabulary of purposes
because it does sound a little too
mystical somehow or a little bit too
much like giving in to the side that
is opposing evolution in the first place
so for some people i think that is one
of their motivations
that they feel that if you use the
language of purpose
you're going to let in the supernatural
and god back into
biology i think there's another
resistance a political resistance to
adaptationist
theory arising that would be exemplified
by
stephen j gould and richard lawnton the
idea is
that thinking that um human nature is in
some sense
adapted fitted to a particular world
is perceived as being a constraint on
the possible worlds and the possible
cultures that
humans can live in and one of one of the
um purposes of my book okay so in
writing it is that i want
to argue that we have evolved to be free
and to make our own choices in
environments that have never been
experienced
before and also that
our human nature expresses the um
the purposes of our genes but they need
not necessarily
be our purposes as individual organisms
so
we we we need to respect human nature
but i'm somewhat of an existentialist
when it comes to
determining what our own purposes should
be our genes don't care about us
if they can get their way by our misery
or by our joy
they will achieve it and so we shouldn't
care too much about
them that's very interesting i mean you
do you do use the example
in the book of uh a person who is very
promiscuous
but uses birth control if i'm
remembering the example correctly and
you you try to make the argument that uh
the original purpose in some sense that
their
motivation to be promiscuous came from
might very well be to spread their
genetic material widely
uh but the actual way they're doing it
doesn't actually succeed in that at all
but it's still okay to use
this language but certainly it's a
reminder that it's tricky
and we should be careful using this
language yeah it's i i recur to that
example a number of times
for for two reasons so one of them
is the reason that you just gave there
sexual activity is pleasurable because
the incentive of pleasure
has been the way the reason why people
have engaged in
activities that have led to reproduction
and genetic transmission
but we can gain the pleasures of
the pleasures from those activities
without
without conception we can use
contraception
the the second reason i use the example
is it makes a distinction
between our psychological motivations
and the reasons why we have those
motivations
so um a philanderer
would not engulf engage in sexual
activity
to have children they engage in sexual
activity because it's psychologically
pleasurable but the reason why it is
pleasurable
is because in the past that sort of
behavior
has um has led to reproduction but we
are not
enslaving to repeat the the past
we should respect our genetic materials
but not too much
[Laughter]
well and also i mean i think you alluded
to this a little bit but
when we tell the story of
why we have this uh urge to
do sexual activity you know there is a
danger
that it's a little bit more storytelling
than scientific right that we tell a
just so story and don't rigorously test
it
how do we know this gets into the whole
useful uh the whole
question about how we can become good
evolutionary psychologists not just
biologists how do we know
that our adaptation of stories are on
the right track so
that that requires critical testing um
to find um distinguishing
um experiments that can be done that can
separate out
alternative explanations particularly in
evolutionary psychology
i think it's very very important to test
ideas
across a wide range of um human cultures
so joe henrich who's professor event
of human evolutionary biology at harvard
has
made uh has written book recently on how
distorting the view of human motivations
it is to just focus on
undergraduate students in evolutionary
psychology labs
i don't i don't see why they wouldn't be
perfectly typical of all human beings
ever but i guess that's a claim you can
think about
yeah so okay um good we
i sort of we've we've jumped ahead to
some of the topics that i am interested
in getting to but
before we just sort of indulge in them
uh let's dig down into a little bit
into the details of what's going on i
know that
what some of the work that you've done
as a research evolutionary biologist
uh emphasizes the fact that we have sort
of competition
going on within ourselves right like if
you try to
say whether this particular gene or this
particular
part of your body has a certain purpose
those purposes might not always align
yes so um the traditional model
of the organism has been of the organism
as
a machine in which all the parts are
working together
for a common good and i'm interested
in situations where that internal
cooperation breaks down and different
genes within the individual
have different fitness function and are
evolving to pursue contradictory
ends i came into it actually
particularly in an interest in genomic
imprinting
where genes of maternal and paternal
origin within the same individual
are subject to conflicting selective
forces so you got to explain more about
that so you're saying that our
our inheritance from mom and dad might
be at odds within ourselves this sounds
like a psychologically rich vein to mine
yes so we we do know that there are some
genes that are differentially expressed
when you get them from mother and father
and so this was called imprinting
because the idea is that there has to be
some mark
put on a gene that said in the last
generation that was in a male or a
female body
and that mark must be inherited by the
offspring and cause the
gene to be expressed in a paternal
specific way or a maternal specific way
but then the imprint must be able to be
erased and reset
because the genes i get from my mother
with the maternal imprint
i'm passing on to my children with the
paternal imprint
so you can think of imprinting as a kind
of temporary annotation
on the text informing the gene of the
in which particular context that's
behaving so i'm particularly interested
in this
in embryonic and fetal development and
in the development of the placenta
and their genes of paternal origin are
tending to favor greater growth of the
placenta which is the structure that's
extracting resources from mothers and
genes of maternal origin in the
same organism are inhibiting placental
development
and so there's an internal conflict on
the size of the placenta
and that comes to some sort of social
resolution of that conflict which has to
be compatible with um
successful development of the child but
it doesn't mean that there aren't
conflict costs involved so that this is
looking at the genome not as
a completely cohesive and cooperative
entity but
as driven with internal conflict and i'm
particularly
interested in situations where evolution
by natural selection
ends up with results that are not good
ideas
that aren't actually increasing the
well-being of organisms
i think a useful analogy here is to
economics
so we're all familiar with adam smith's
idea of the invisible hand
the basic idea there is that everybody
following their
own self-interests everything gets
delivered
more efficiently at a cheaper price
and the invisible hand is good for many
aspects of the economy
but it's particularly bad at the
provision of public goods as we're
seeing in global warming
and the collapse of the world fisheries
and congestions in the streets within
cities so these are situations where
there are
public goods that nobody owns and
everybody enjoys
and the self-interest is very bad at
providing
public goods and the same thing applies
in evolutionary biology
the idea that natural selection is
leading to ever increasing fitness and
well-being of organism
is true in some contexts but i'm in
interested in situations of public goods
where
evolution by natural selection leads to
outcomes that
are not necessarily fission and so for
an example i would use
that they call it the tragedy of the
maternal commons
that you have embryos fetuses that
are um over exploiting internal
resources during um
because if one one offspring does not
take those resources
they go to another offspring that isn't
genetic the same as that one
and so though a cooperative outcome
would be the most efficient
you lead to a situation in which there
are
conflict costs and i think this explains
why um
things go wrong so often during
pregnancy
at force at first sight it's um strange
my my heart and my liver have been
functioning very well for
for 62 years and yet during pregnancy
you have a natural process that only
lasts for
nine months and yet many things go wrong
during it
and i would argue that the reason why
pregnancy doesn't work as smoothly
as the normal functioning of the body is
that in normal bodily functioning
all the parts of the body are
genetically identical to each other
and working towards survival of that
body but in pregnancy you have two
different
genetic individuals interacting with
each other and natural selection can act
at
cross purposes there's a sort of
politics going on
and we know that politics does not
always lead to
efficient outcomes i i've heard that
yeah i've i've seen it
in action even sometimes but maybe you
could uh
illuminate a little bit more the
molecular biology here because i think
like many people i have this simplistic
high school
notion high school biology notion of we
get half our dna from mom half of it
from dad and now it's our dna and it all
works together but
you're saying that there's somehow a
chemical marker in there
that tells me whether it's from mom or
dad but that there's not a chemical
marker that tells me
about whether it's from grandmom or
grandad so
um we don't definitely know the answer
to the second part about grand parental
origin but we do
definitely know that there are markers
of maternal or paternal
origin and for many of the genes this is
by a process
called um dna methylation so
the cytosine nucleotide can have a
methyl group attached that's just a
single carbon atom with three hydrogens
attached
and so they're enzymes that can attach
methyl groups to cytosine
and enzymes that can remove that and
then during dna
replication there is also a process by
which
the daughter cells inherit the inherit
the pattern of
cytosine methylation from the parental
spell
and so now you've got all the molecular
tools for putting marks onto dna
that are stably transmitted through many
cell divisions
and even from parent to offspring but
then you also have biochemical processes
that can remove those
remarks and re reset them so this is the
example i was giving of a
of an annotation of the genetic text
well and it leads us directly into
something you'd
mention in the book also which is this
idea of the selfishness
of uh not just people or organisms but
of different substructures richard
dawkins very famously
suggested that we think of genes as
being selfish and so
uh i don't want to put words in your
mouth but you you think that there is a
sense in which that's a good way of
thinking about
even individual genes yes no i i think
that
um the adaptations of genes are for the
benefit of those genes
so in that sense the genes are being
metaphorically
selfish i think that genes are the
direct targets of natural selection
they are the selfish agents that does
not mean that genes may not
um construct bodies individual organisms
that
achieve propagate achieve the selfish
genes
the selfish ends of their genes by
cooperative
behaviors so i'm thinking of
individual organisms or as interpreters
as i
called them later in the the book as
being different kinds of
entities than genes so genes in
dawkins terms are selfish that does not
necessarily
mean that the organisms they construct
need be selfish they sometimes are
selfish but they can also be
cooperative well this i mean maybe this
is a good place to ask a
confusion or a fuzziness i've had for a
long time about this because
genes in some sense
some collection of dna that does some
function um are the things that are
passed
down through um evolution through sexual
reproduction etc
but traits of organisms are what
selection pressures actually act on
right like whether the giraffe's neck is
long or whether the
you know person is strong or swift or
whatever so is
how complicated is that relationship
between the information carried through
in the genes
and the macroscopic traits that are
actually subject to selection pressures
so the analogy i use at the end of the
book is of natural selection as a poet
um but it's the so if you look at a poet
a poem it's how all the parts relate to
each other
um so that a a word doesn't have an
isolated meaning
but its meaning is with respect to the
poem as a
as a whole but when you're writing a
poem it's always a voice among
alternatives this word versus that
they're judged by their effects on the
the whole
but the process of um choice is between
um additive alternatives and so natural
selection is always
choosing this genetic variant versus
another
variant but it's in the context of their
consequences for the the complicated
whole organism
so the way that i think of it is that
natural selection is a mindless process
just choosing among
simple alternatives but choosing among
those
alternatives in terms of their effect on
the
complicated um whole and so that's how
we get these very very
um complicated organisms now i think
this
has solitary implications for for the
attempt to
understand organisms from the bottom up
isolating
it's just like isolating a single word
in a low amount of context
and asking what is the meaning of that
word
you're losing um you're losing you're
losing all of the poetry in life in
approaching um explanation um from that
bottom-up perspective
well yeah and and this it once again
speaks to the usefulness i think of this
multi-level way of thinking that
different vocabularies have different
explanatory power
uh depending on your sort of level of
resolution at which you talk about
things which immediately leads to the
question of um if genes can be selfish
then
what does that imply about uh when
people talk about
kin selection or group selection you
know can we look at
uh categories that are larger than
individual organisms and their genomes
and fruitfully apply darwinian ideas to
them
yes so um an alternative to
gene selectionism has been multi-level
selectionism
i just think these are different ways of
carving nature at the
joint that they're defining fundamental
terms in different
ways so um hierarchical selection theory
or multi-level selection theory
thinks as genes as the lowest level of a
hierarchy
so there are genes within cells and
cells within bodies
and bodies within groups and groups
within ecosystem
and that's implicitly defining a gene as
a physical object that's sitting within
the
cell whereas the idea of the gene
in richard dawkins and in gene
selectionism is this is a bit of
information
that can be distributed across multiple
levels of that
hierarchy and so a gene in my liver
has been selected because it promotes
the propagation of its copies
in my sperm cells and in kin selection
a gene in my brother's liver could be
selected
because it favors the propagation of its
copies
in my sperm cells so there's nothing
about
gene selectionism that isolates the gene
to a particular organism that bit of
information
can be distributed across multiple
levels of the
hierarchy so i think a lot of arguments
in evolutionary
biology which is better gene
selectionism or multi-level selectionism
are really semantic arguments and the
two sides are just
i'm using the same language but defining
the terms in very different senses
well i mean there's a provocative image
that you just
gave to us that in some sense rather
than
the gene as a bit of dna
we can think of it as a bit of
information and it's information that is
spread out in complicated ways through a
population
and despite the abstractness of that
idea
you you seem again i don't want to put
words into your mouth
but you seem to want to give in to the
temptation to use a language of
purpose and almost anthropomorphic ways
of thinking about that and i'm going to
let you do that but maybe
defend that as as strongly as you can if
you think this is a good idea
oh difficult questions
part of the book is actually looking at
the
relationship between information and
meaning
i've just decided that i'm being like um
the politicians we've heard on debates
where i've changed the uh
um the questions somewhat that's you're
right in this case
i'm not going to uh pinpoint you say the
things you think are interesting to say
yes so uh i think the central
chapter in the book is actually an
account of a relationship between
information and meaning so that if you
go back to
claude shannon and his idea of
information theory
information was just the uncertainty
that was dispelled by
perceiving one bit of information one
signal rather than
another one so it was a purely
quantitative
conception and there was um it's been
remarkably affecting
effective in commuter computer science
in cybernetics and in
all sorts of areas of um technology but
there was a pushback against that
that's not what we meant by information
in
information we're asking what does it
mean
that the information is about something
it refers to
particular things in the um world right
and i so i would like to separate
meaning from information that
me so the central concept of the later
parts of the book is the idea of an
interpreter
which is an intentional being um it's
like you and i
but it could also be a little bit of rna
that's um
taking information from the environment
responding in some
adaptive sort of way and so an
interpreter
is coupling what i in physics term
think of as two entropies one of the
entropies is an uncertainty
and that is resolved by observation of
information
and the second uncertainty the second
entropy is an indecision
all the possible um things that the
organism could do
and that indecision is revolt resolved
by choice
taking an action and interpretation is
pure
is the all the complicated processes
that have evolved by natural selection
that connect the input of information
on the resolution of uncertainty into
choice of action
resolving indecision into particular
actions now if you think about
an input output devices in purely
physical terms
um you have there are an incredibly
large number of ways that you can
connect up
um the same inputs to to the same set of
um outputs
and most of those connections are
non-meaningful it's the
process of natural selection that
creates
meaning in terms of output and choice of
of action
from the information that the organism
is acquiring from its
environment so i i tentatively love this
idea i think that a lot of the um
audience members will be surprised that
we've managed to get this far into the
podcast without using the word entropy
because i use the word entropy
all the time so may i ask is this a
suggestion of thinking of information uh
as resolving some kind of certainty into
action and that's the origin of meaning
is this a
a a technical thing you've written up
with all the equations and everything or
is this something that's more
aspirational that you're that you would
like to
see come true and further research well
i i think actually
that um i deliberately avoided so
shannon information um you know his
measure of information is just like a
measure of entropy and that
that side of theory has been um very
well quantified
in equations written but i think the
meaning of information
um you could quantify how you know the
um
the pos all possible choices of action
of an organism
um and put a measure on that but i think
that i'm trying to
quantify there is actually missing the
the point of the relationship between
meaning
and information that it's trying to
substitute a quantitative measure for
something that is inherently
qualitative so i guess that's one of the
more radical
um implications of the book that i
that i think quantification is actually
missing the
point in um some of these um biological
systems
i mean you definitely caught me i'm very
tempted to write down some equations and
quantify this but i think i i
take your point it no the equations can
be
written down and they can be useful
so different organisms um almost
certainly
vary in the range and the repertoire of
responses
they can make to the information in the
environment and you might be able to
quantify it but the quantities
themselves
is not telling you anything about the
sort of decisions that a slug makes
versus the sort of decisions that a
human makes and
the quantification is not i'm telling
you
the reasons why this decision is made
rather another decision
okay yeah that that is fair enough um
but it also
it opens up a new possibility it's not
very new by now
but uh another one of dawkins's ideas is
the idea of
memes not just of genes right of of
ideas themselves
uh having a sort of evolutionary history
and i think this is a i'm not sure what
the status
of this conception is throughout
different academic fields but you seem
to be coming down on the side saying
that yes we should think of ideas
in this memeology kind of way so i i
think
um ideas and culture clearly evolve
and um they are subject to an
analogues of natural selection whether
there's anything
you know you when you think of a gene as
a physical object you can point to
a particular sequence on a dna molecule
and i don't think in
mimetic or cultural evolution that
there's anything with that sort of
simplicity that you can point to so i
think
ideas of memes are good thought
experiments for thinking about um
culture but i don't think that there's
going to be as well developed science of
mimetics where
we're treating particular ideas as
discrete
means as there has been in for example
theoretical population genetics in the
feedback on the book i've received so
so far from biologists
the two points in which there's been
most resistance
is my use of teleological language
which um people still resist strongly
and then the second is
on the use of the language of memes
which many biologists
feel that it's bringing the massiveness
of
culture and meaning into into biology
and then there's also resistance to that
from the side of the humanities which is
thinking it's a
far too simplistic approach to what they
see as a very very um
complicated process of cultural
evolution well
so i have sympathy um with that position
but i also um think that thinking about
what are the reasons the cultures are
the way they are what are the
meanings of those cultures and that may
not be always
you know choices that humans have made
cultures evolve
by processes that aren't um
unplanned by the the people that are
living in those cultures
well if people are objecting or at least
commenting on your use of teleology and
your use of memes can we
combine them to talk about selfish memes
i'm just interested
in how far we can go in thinking
of these rather abstract notions in
sort of anthropomorphic language and you
know parenthetically
maybe the fact that the language is
anthropomorphic is beside the point i
mean
a more interesting question is uh are
these the right units of analysis or
levels of description where we can sort
of
get a lot of understanding by thinking
in this vocabulary
yeah so i would think now you know the
the world we're living in with social
media and the internet
and email we are just being bombarded
all the time um by bits of information
um cultural items that are being sent
out by other people
in the hope that we will sort of pass
that they will change our behavior and
that we will pass them
them on and so how do we cope with that
um
there are some things that appeal to us
and others
that don't appeal to us and the ones
that appeal
are then transmitted and the ones that
don't appeal
um don't become memes in the the common
armed sense
so if if you look at a um
an idea or a bit of news or uh
a theory that goes viral another um
another biological metaphor um
the reason why it goes viral and
distributed is because of the
properties that it has that appeals to
the people who are seeing the idea and
now i'm not talking about whether it's
true or wrong whether it's real news or
fake news but the things that are
transmitted are those that appeal to
human minds
and so the ideas that are out there are
evolving
often not deliberately by people to
appeal
to be attractive to human minds to be
the sort of things that we want to
transmit to
other individuals and that's really what
i'm attempting to do in my book
i'm attempting to um persuade
to write about a pers to try and make a
set of ideas
as persuasive as possible so that um
your listeners and hopefully the book's
readers will
um use them to influence their own
thinking and to pass them on
yeah am i am i remembering correctly
that
in your book you you give dennett uh
credit for the idea
that this is a way of thinking about
what makes human beings unique
in the world of biology the fact that we
have this memeology the fact that we
pass on ideas and abstract forms and
those ideas come back
and feedback and affect how we live in
the societies we build
yeah so dan dennett has made that point
um but it's a much older idea that the
really fundamentally um distinctive
thing about human beings is that we have
um
cultural evolution right to an extent
far beyond that of any other
organism and i think culture
that sort of open-ended cultural
evolution has been made possible
by the origin of language and so
language is a medium that now allows
ideas to be transmitted from person to
person
much more efficiently and with much
higher information
content than the sort of communication
that we see
in other organisms and certainly one of
the
sets of abstract ideas that we have and
that we use
is what you might label moral philosophy
right a sense of right and wrong like
animals clearly there are things that
they want to do and things they don't
want to do but they don't
talk about meta ethics in the same way
that human beings do so
you have an angle on that right you're
you're not afraid to
to say how these ideas we've been
talking about for last hour
uh have an impact on how we should think
about right and wrong in questions of
morality
yes so i think that um
all of our repertoire of emotions
our benevolence our generosity
our nastiness our jealousy
these are all passions that
um have evolved as um means of getting
us
to um do to to transmit our own genes
if um they will you know we feel
miserable
because that in the past has been a way
of um
tran in certain environments um
promoting our survival
and reproduction but now
that we are we are cultural beings we
can look at that
repertoire of feelings and motions we
have and we can decide that we like some
of them
that some of them are good and that
others are
bad or perhaps even evil and we have
evolved
a certain degree of autonomy to choose
our own motivations in life
and so i think of moral systems as
human inventions there are technologies
of living together in the world
and just like all technologies they have
bugs
and that as the world changes
technologies become
outdated but i have a real
respect for moral questions but i think
that they're not um
directly coming from our revolutionary
past that they're actually
cultural inventions constructs that we
attempt to use to live together with
each other
well i i mean you're preaching to the
converted as it were because
that's very compatible with uh the point
of view i took in the big picture so
therefore i am um empowered to play the
devil's advocate and give you a hard
time about it
uh because i'm on your side already but
i think that if we could conjure up a
skeptic they would say well
that that picture you're saying maybe
sounds a little circular right i mean of
course we evolve we're naturalistic
beings so we have
desires we have individual goals there
are things that we
want and what's different uh between
what you said
and just me saying that morality is a
scheme i cook up
to get as much of my desire satisfied as
i want i mean that sounds very different
than a
a classical more realist would want
things to be you know the
a a moral system um has to be
accepted by the the society as a whole
so we cannot just um impose our own
particular
um selfish views on the rest of
individuals
so that that is the first thing i'd say
i think another
theme of my book is that um you might
gather when you read the book
i'm not opposed to circular arguments i
think that um i shouldn't say you know a
circle just comes back to the same point
but the whole
principle of life is that it's recursive
that um and the analogy i use in the
book a lot is chickens and eggs
right eggs develop into chickens and
then chickens lay
eggs that develop into chickens so
life itself is circular is circular
or recursive it constantly repeats
and it's that repetition um
from which meaning and purpose evolves
it's because because of the recursive
nature that the genes effects
have a causal role in whether that gene
is
perpetuated so when when you look at say
the origin of morality
and argue that um the position i'm
taking is
a i'm somewhat circular position i
i i would say what's the what's the
what's the problem with a
recursive um argument right i was
greatly
influenced actually um by it's not
really acknowledged in the book but by
douglas hoff's that is um girdle escher
and bach
that i read when i was an undergraduate
and it's all about
the odd features of recursion and
self-reference
and um natural selection is a recursive
self-referential um process and it has a
lot of the
very odd properties that hofstadter
wrote about in that book
i mean the philosopher would just say
that you're finding a reflective
equilibrium
between you know the the urges you have
but but i think i guess your point is
that we also have higher cognitive
capacities that can go beyond
just uh fulfill our urges and and
create something more so i mean the the
worry is that it just becomes the
naturalistic fallacy that you say that
what exists in nature already is good
that we should find our purpose
from whatever we evolve to do and call
that uh moral or natural or good
uh and i think that the point of view
that you're putting forward is a little
bit more sophisticated than that
so i'm definitely um
definitely do not um believe in the
naturalistic fallacy
that i believe that it's part about all
of the good things that we're capable of
and all of the evil terrible things that
we're capable of
are part of our evolved nature
so that to behave morally to just go
back to
um to our evolutionary past i think
that's fundamentally
misunderstanding the choices that we
have to make in our life
here and now that we have evolved
to make choices in environments that
have never occurred before
the world we're living in now is very
very
different from the world and past and we
have that flexibility because
organisms that were able to make their
own decisions
rather than just rely on instinct were
able to survive better than purely
instinctual beings
and so we have acquired a freedom that
can then look at our own motivations and
choose some of them
as preferable to others so that
um yes no i'm definitely not arguing for
um getting back to to nature right and
this this
this importance of recursion is clear
throughout the book but you also
do something a little mischievous with
it
in that you relate it to french thinker
jacques derrida
there does right there in the title of
your book from darwin to darada and i
think that
among many scientists uh he is
not just the symbol of sort of
nonsensical obscuritanism and i'm not
one of those scientists but
maybe i can give you the opportunity to
explain why you thought that daradah
would be a good
uh perspective to bring into this
discussion
of uh of evolution and morality and
meaning well
the original title uh well one of the
titles i had for the book
was degrees of freedom and um for a
variety of reasons that
title was not available and one of the
themes of the book that i wanted to make
was
that natural selection is the process
by which meaning and purpose come into a
world without meaning and purpose
so meaning and purpose are traditionally
the concerns of the humanities and the
uh and the social sciences
so i wanted to um talk to that community
as well as to a biological
community and very late actually in the
writing of the
um book i started to think of genesis
texts and so i went to look at what the
humanities had to say in texts
and i read some of derrida's um works um
on how um the meaning is continually
being rewritten that there is no
original um sense to a to a text
and i found that there were a lot of um
parallels to
um to what i was thinking about in um
biological evolution
i'm including my um resistance to
the idea of that the adapt that i think
of
things function is what was ever the
original
um what it originally evolved to do
whereas i think that the
the functions and purposes of things are
continually changing
and so that sense of um change i
see parallels to um derrida and once i
decided to take the title
um derrida um beli is opposed to the
metaphysics of
presence of the idea that there is um
some sort of reality out there that
that exists independent of our
interpretations of it
and so i um thought of a conceit of i'm
calling the book darwin to derrida and
never actually mentioning him through
there
through the whole book but i decided
that would be uh
far too um sophisticated a
a joke so he has mentioned um sparingly
but i think that there are um parallels
between
the idea in literary theory that um that
meanings are
continually being reinterpreted at every
writing and rewriting of the text
and that the functions and purposes of
life are continually being reinterpreted
as the genetic text is evolving because
of its interaction
with the environment and i would say in
evolutionary biology natural selection
is is the process by which
um information from the environment
is being encoded in the the genetic
material
and so the genetic material then comes
to refer to
um that very very complex environment so
it's sort of it's it's not that um
it's not a one it's a recursive process
so information in the genes is being
expressed in
the development of organisms but the
information in the genes
is coming from the complex interactions
of those
organisms with their environment yeah
and actually i really i really really
like that and i like that explanation
you just gave
it illuminates um what i got out of
reading the book very clearly i mean
i i'm torn a little bit because i as a
theoretical physicist i have to be
foundationalist in some sense i think
that there is a real world the physical
world and probably
you agree with that and darren bader da
you know uh he said a lot of things but
one constant theme was this
anti-foundationalist
of course he wasn't thinking about
physics he was thinking about uh meaning
in culture and and literal literature
and philosophy
and there i'm very sympathetic and i
think that you're right that uh
you know whether you're whether people
are very religious or completely atheist
they there's this strong desire to find
absolutely unshakable foundations right
and you know descartes made it very
clear but
it's still clear today in a lot of
atheist thinkers and the idea that
morality and meaning and purpose in life
is not
solved by a simple algorithm but rather
something that emerges from a
complicated web of interconnected things
uh going back and forth with each other
makes people a little a little nervous a
little queasy
a little dizzy and uh learning to accept
that is hard
yeah no i'm i'm uh i am a believer in a
in a real world i'm all
all that we have are our perceptions and
our perceptions
are interpretations of the world but
we can trust our perceptions
especially when we're interacting with
the non-non-living world
because our perceptions have evolved to
be useful
um our perceptions are are are accurate
because they're grounded in the need to
know
the example i use is of a gazelle
fleeing from a from a cheetah it
definitely
needs to you know know what what that
cheater is doing
how it is um moving because if it
doesn't know
it will be eaten and so
i do believe that our perceptions
do give us objective
information about the world
it's a little bit more complex in our
interaction
with other individuals because other
individuals may
have our motives to um
to manipulate our own perceptions to
change our interpretations of the world
and we have motivations to manipulate
them and so when it comes to the world
of interpersonal
um relations i'm not sure that we can uh
trust trust our perceptions of things
because we may have um
because we may have motives to deceive
including motives to deceive ourselves
so i'm uh i'm quite a relativist
in um the realm of human interactions
but in terms of our perceptions of the
the physical world
and with limitations i think we can um
though our perceptions are subjective
they have evolved to give us objectively
useful
information right yeah no okay i'm i'm
completely on board here so
i mean maybe to wrap things up um since
we have been on board uh
i can bring up to you a criticism that
was made of my book which i think is a
yeah halfway fair criticism that
uh i talked a lot about meta ethics
and meta meaning in some sense right
like what it means to distinguishing
right and wrong and where meaning might
come from
but much less about how i would actually
say uh what is right and wrong what is
the correct moral system or what is the
meaning of life that that that kind of
thing i mean from your
evolutionary perspective uh do you do
you think that there is
useful information or insight you can
give to people about
not just the origins of morality and
meaning but what the actual
morals and meaning should be that we
choose to live by
so the the way i put it in the book is
that the
the meaning of life is the life that is
lived um
that our lives are an interpretation
of the information we get from
our environment and i and the meaning
you know in my conception of meaning is
that interpretation we are
we are judged by the choices that we
make each you know there is there
there is a meaning of each individual
life and that's one that we
um in some sense create for ourselves i
wouldn't say that there's
an overarching meaning of life
considered as an abstract um abstract
entity right and so that's that's why i
deliberately use the plural in the title
yeah it's about the meanings of life
there is a meaning to the life of each
individual slug
there is a meaning to the life of each
individual human being
and in some sense that that meaning is
defined
by the choices the interpretation of
that organism
yeah i mean i i did a podcast a solo
podcast uh for my 100th anniversary my
100th podcast episode where i talked
about the meaning of life
in a little bit more substantive way
than i did in
the big picture and i said that uh i
mean like you there's not one final
meaning but there can be individual
meanings that different people come up
with
and actually this is something that i
haven't yet mentioned in the podcast i
wanted to
ask you about which is the fact that in
biology in genomics or
in human life the space of possibility
uh is unimaginably large right i mean
the number of possible
dna sequences are the number of possible
choices you can make to live your life
and evolution is sort of one
algorithm or procedure for kind of
searching through there and we can talk
about how efficient it is but so i
brought up the
the idea that we can think about
meaningfulness in life
from diverging from the easiest possible
path
in all those choices that we make right
there are things we can do
that we put value on that are harder
than just going with the flow
and that's where meaningfulness comes
from is that something you'd be
sympathetic to
yes um i i think uh
you know just repeating what's done in
the
past well the the the metaphor i
um i used that one place in the um
book is of um playing a card of hands
um that uh that the cards are ancient
um you know the the particular genes
that um
that we are dealt but each individual
life is unique it's a unique combination
and it's what we do with that card of
hands that we're dealt that is in
that is important um and some people
are going to be given a very very poor
card of hands and others
a um you know get get a very good
hand that is hard to lose with but we
are judged by what we
do with the cards that we are dealt
right i think that's a very good way of
putting it and a perfect place to wrap
up so david hague thanks so much for
being on the mindscape podcast
thank you sean
[Music]
you
[Music]